let's go next to our caller from the 385
area code who's calling today from 385.
hi david this is laura from somerville
math
laura in somerville laura tell me
let me just question let me ask you
something what's going on with my
favorite
somerville cafe diesel cafe i obviously
have not been there since the start of
the pandemic are they doing okay
i think so they're just doing a lot of
just
take out got it okay well i hope to get
back there when things normalize
yeah um so my question is about the
if you're following the primary race
here in
massachusetts the kennedy marquee and
kind of what your
thoughts on that race are so listen i i
have
friends that are working on both
campaigns the re-election campaign for
ed markey
and the challenge campaign um for
for uh kennedy and i have to tell you
i am very strongly leaning towards marky
it's not obvious to me that kennedy is
uh you know some progressive hero of any
kind
he strikes me as relatively
establishment
i don't know that there's much benefit
to replacing a senior senator
with someone who would be the lowest on
the totem pole in a legislative body
like the senate where seniority matters
so much uh i believe that um the debate
was
very bad for kennedy uh and marky did
very well so i'm just not seeing
if i'm if i want to make a change it
needs to be
super clear to me that we're making a
change for the better and i'm just i'm
not at all convinced of that right now
okay yeah that's kind of where i've been
at i've lived here for 10 years and
since i moved here
i mean marky has always seemed to be on
the right side of things from a
progressive standpoint
so just curious where you were with that
so the other thing that i've not loved
about the kennedy ads is this idea that
it's his time sort of just making an age
case where like he's younger than marky
and it's in now to replace
older democrats with younger democrats
and that
that i don't find that to be
particularly good
uh reasoning particularly when you're
talking about
again losing the seniority that ed
markey has so that i've been a little
turned off by those ads
right well and also kind of that idea of
something new when he's a kennedy
like let's not forget that part that's a
fair point as well yeah and i you know i
don't care so much about that but i
think that that's a reasonable
reasonable point as well yeah right
okay well thanks all right thank you for
the call
hope to be back up in summerville soon
appreciate it thank you
let's see if we can hear from our caller
from the 206 area code who's calling
today from 206
is that me yes it is hello yes that's
yes this is the this is the misanthropic
curmudgeon from seattle
okay can you maybe just be don't quite
yell
so much into the phone and i think we're
gonna hear you fine
okay can you hear me now yes that's
better
okay i actually had a couple statements
and then a question
okay uh the first statement is that uh
thanks to trump
i think we now officially live in that
[ __ ] country between canada and
mexico
right and my other statement
is that i believe a free country should
be founded on integrity and empathy
with four fundamental foundations of no
harm
no take
no betrayal and no destruction okay
um that that being said what is our
breaking point
with this unconstitutional criminality
that
we are compelled to do something next
level to take our country back
wait wait so which unconstitutional
criminality are you referring to
well just in general with the
corporations not paying taxes
mitch mcconnell not pushing through
voter protections and
just the list is endless okay i mean i
think the answer is
the portland the portland federal age i
mean how much more
will we endure this tyranny right before
it collapses
well so what do you want to do about it
tell me what you what's your plan
well i'd like to see national
initiatives where we actually hear from
the people
yeah on what they want on a national
level instead of state by state
okay and then what kind of actions would
you like to see are you talking about
mass rallies mass callouts from work
strategic defaults what what are we what
are you thinking of well
my understanding of the way the country
is supposed to work is we elect
people to represent us but what has
happened in essence
is we are electing people to overlord
over us
and that's i think the fundamental
problem is we don't have
a representative government the
government does whatever it wants and we
just have to take it
well we can we can vote on someone else
right we could vote in someone else
except that once you get someone in as
in the case of trump
then he's there what he does he you know
he's dually elected this and due process
that
but he's erased all of that with his
contemptuous unconstitutional tyrannical
behavior
well we've got to remove him in three
months then right
i'm sorry to hear that we've got to
remove him in three months then for sure
yes but there's still the residual of
the mitch mcconnell's the steve mnuchin
absolutely absolutely well listen check
out my video
trumpism doesn't end when trump leaves
because that's exactly the heart of uh
of what i'm getting at listen i
appreciate the call i think your
questions
you're asking some big questions they
may be even too big for me
but i think you're thinking about a lot
of the right things thanks to everybody
who called in and as always i apologize
i'm not able to take
every phone call we're going to take a
break and we will be back
right after this